[Music]
hey you guys welcome to awesome comics
your one-stop shop for everything comic
book entertainment on Ayana and I've
taken over today we're back with our vs.
series in our vs. series we take two
panelists and we make them fight out
their opposing views right here this is
I'm ready man you will kick my ass we're
gonna move this table away and they're
just now just gonna yeah well today's
topic is mask versus Deadpool so who's
the better wacky character we'll get
into specifics in a moment but first I
want to go ahead and encourage you to go
like our Facebook page every Thursday we
have an exclusive video that comes out
just for you on Facebook so go check it
out get alike let us know what you're
thinking about this stuff other stuff
things we should do in the future we'd
like to hear from you so why don't we
get into intros Doug welcome back to the
show
how are you doing today I'm doing good
um I am Doug you doing well I'm doing
well O'Bannon does good oh yeah I can do
good too well good I'm glad to hear that
I mean I won't but I could well it's the
fact that you code that counts yes and
Porter hi welcome back you're here sir
mr. Feeny would love you to do good mmm
that's right tearjerker
so last episode anyway what's up not
what we're here to talk about but always
always important to bring us yeah you
can always bring up mr. Feeny mr. Feeny
versus boy that should be the neck all
right well let's get into a little bit
of the history of each of these
characters um Doug why don't you start
us off tell us a little bit about the
mess
the mask is very much like the movie
except polar-opposite it that makes
sense
it's about a guy named stanley ipkiss
who finds his artifact this mask and
when he puts it on suddenly he's
transformed to his green face Menace but
instead of going around helping people
and doing good he goes around killing
people and doing whatever he wants and
nobody can stop him nobody can shoot him
or kill him he might bleed a little bit
but he's totally invulnerable but the
great thing about is that doesn't just
stay with him it passes from person to
person to person and we see the
different impact that it has on those
people and it turns you crazy it turns
you violate it turns you
super insane and it's always a battle
whether or not they can get it away from
them in time and it's one of the coolest
most gory action series ever it's
twisted it strange it's incredible
all righty then Porter why don't you
take it was smoking thank you
which is not in the comic by the way
whoo do not know in there Oh
childhood we need to have a Jim Carrey
talking yeah and we will oh we're
partnered talk a little bit about
Deadpool Wayde Winston Wilson aka
Deadpool whose first appearance was in
New Mutants 98 February 91 written by
Fabian Nicieza and drawn by Rob Liefeld
is a human mercenary mutated by weapon
exes edition of Wolverines healing
factor which bonded to his cancer wait
whose memories of his childhood are
conflicting was raised by his mother and
abusive father who was an army officer
and was later killed by one of Wade's
friends when Wade was a teen later after
getting out of the Army Special Forces
for not following orders Wade joined a
CIA agency for mercs later he joined the
u.s. Canadian run department k2 helped
cure his cancer it was arrested for a
bit but then came back after killing a
teammate he had his heart ripped out by
Ajax in retaliation for killing his
teammate and his healing factor kicked
in and saved his life he tracked down a
Jackson killed him and then adopted the
name Deadpool
oh well informative thank you gentlemen
you're all welcome so obviously in the
history the healing factor
invulnerability abilities builder
there's um it's very important probably
very important part of these characters
so let's get down to it let's talk about
who is the best healing factor or
invulnerability doc let's start with you
okay so the great thing about the mask
is that when you put it on it's not like
someone gets shot and you know if
there's blood and there's a little hole
that just stays there whatever with the
mask it can work however you want to
work there's some scenes where like a
million people will shoot them and
there's not a scratch on I mean it's
like a little bit of fire or something
like that like that's it like a candle
or there's other times where he'll get
shot I'll be just boring with blood
stuff like that sometimes the bullets
get stuck in them sometimes they go
through sometimes when you take its head
off it can actually come straight off
other times the neck will stretch it's
very much cartoon watch it gets whatever
it wants to be so I think it might be
and that's like the ultimate
vulnerability because it's whatever you
want it's whatever serves the joke it's
very much like a cartoon that way and
it's also what serves its purpose in you
know winning the battle or just doing
whatever crazy emotional thing he or she
wants to do and I think that kind of
what makes it so cool and makes it so
imagine it is that there is no one
continuity with the vulnerability is
just however he or she wants to do it
until the mask comes off until the mask
comes off yeah which case like you
probably have like a hole in your shirt
you know from like bullets or something
like that but your skin and everything
is totally fine so the mass is actually
just the face or it's the whole body
then it's I mean it only visually it
just takes over the face usually but
even then that's not true because they
can like suddenly you know give you see
yeah you can certainly have like a sue
then you can have like a guitar you can
have whatever you want
um but uh yeah the main thing is the
green it just protects the entire body
and you can pull out whatever you want
before it was just guns but as the
comics went on and movie came out
suddenly you know you can bring animals
out and all sorts of crazy people and
things and stuff like that so it kicks
ass awesome awesome speaking of kicking
ass Deadpool let's talk about I am
straight okay so Deadpool's and
vulnerability is uh out of all the
healers in the Marvel Universe you got
his invulnerability from Wolverine but
then the saber-tooth also got also got
it from over een and then there's a
Dakin and x-23 but out of all of them he
has the best healing factor it is the
fastest and the most complete uh in
Deadpool suicide Kings he gets his head
literally blown apart by a crossbow bolt
from the Punisher it just grows back no
problem he uses it to his advantage all
the time slicing off an arm slicing off
a leg you know if someone's got him in a
hold or whatever he just I'm gonna chop
this off I'm gonna pull it off by
through whatever and he uses it to get
out of situations he uses it to help his
mission to trick people all the time you
use
to his advantage a lot and it is it is
awesome he can just cut stuff off like
attach it his healing factor just
instantly bonds back his arm or whatever
he uses it to his advantage so much and
it is so fast even getting his head
blown off he grows the back in like an
hour
sure if you're in the middle of a fight
that kind of sucks but if someone goes
your head off and they're gonna be like
well he's dead we're gonna walk away
little do they know his head goes back
and he comes and screws them up it is an
awesome tool that he uses to his
advantage all the time I think that's a
little bit more useful to him than just
the mass because when say someone knows
it's stanley ipkiss okay means the mass
they try to kill him he doesn't die
later on takes the mask off on let's see
stanley ipkiss he blows his freaking
head off Stanley's dead
spoilers oh I didn't know that see it's
obviously gonna happen but with Deadpool
it's it's all the time
he's always got it no matter what he's
doing when you handle though when you're
in a battle actually going at it like
you're said he gets his head blown off
or something like that you know he's got
a grab bag he's got weird something like
that you know you're right with the
weakness with the mask it does have to
eventually come off or you'll go nuts um
but when you do actually have the mask
on like you know if you if it hits you
and you don't want your head to fly back
or you do want to come clean off so you
can throw back at them or something like
that you can do that I think there's
just so much more opportunity with that
it's always more useful in the battle to
it's like those flamingo things from the
labyrinth those guys get that scene
every time alright now I exciting
exciting topic I'm excited - I'm so
excited how excited you're excited most
creative killer chaos go creative kill
or Te'o yeah mmm okay well my see I like
ones actually even for the masks it's
not like super weird or anything like
that I think it's super funny Alec kills
where the prison doesn't even
necessarily kill the prey he lets other
people kill him and there's this one
great one again what I was talking about
before with playing the bullets either
go through or get stuck he's in between
this why he's talking to one guy who has
a shotgun at him and he's walking to the
door he's tantalizing and stuff and he
goes through the door and there's
another guy with a shotgun Adam and he
tantalizes am you know howdy ha and they
both fire the guns and they go right
through
get the other guy it's just this
beautifully drawn frame of them both
firing at the same time and both of them
flying back in this wall in the middle
where you know the master just going
haha you know and just you finally take
a look you see his blood pouring out the
mask he's just looking at to me just
goes man you know whatever so I really
like the ones where again he could sir
use his his power to his advantage and
just sort of like you know I can hear
stop these are just let them go right
through me and let them go right through
and to kill each other
yeah and that's the nice version that's
like the cop who has the mask it that
way that's the nicer of the people and
he just lets them kill each other what's
one of the worst so like an honorable
mention of like a worse like terrible
gritty one that's a lot of the most
creative come from Walter Walter is like
one of the most twisted demented
characters and he barely talks he's kind
of like I'm in the chair we're not
talking about Walter okay
hi-oh and the character in the comic is
alright I got I got if Deadpool is good
at anything it's good at killing people
in the most awesome awesome ways okay
one of my favorite runs of Deadpool is
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe busy
freaking murders
everybody what's one of the biggest
powerhouses
in Marvel who's who's one of the biggest
badasses that just can't be killed
also you're stuck no I think bigger and
more godlike Oh Thor Thor Thor is a
badass he can go toe-to-toe with anybody
he usually wins
Deadpool kills Thor and he doesn't even
touch him he blows up the Avengers tower
most of them die the sanad II just got
done killing Luke Cage Thor's like
you'll need more than some bombs to beat
me and he throws mule near at him
Deadpool does a quick cool flip
he's got Hank Pym Pym particle helmet
shoots the hammer with some Pym
particles close it up to huge size when
it misses Deadpool it comes back around
to Thor like it should Wham smacks the
shit out of him and kills him awesome
awesome you just crushed Thor with a
giant size Mjolnir and you didn't even
touch him that is one of the most badass
kills I've ever seen but if you want
more gory later on an issue 3 of that
series he
he's taunting Wolverine and he shows him
a picture actually
Wolverine goes to the place we've got on
x-23 and Dakin strung up hanging from
the roof all burnt to shit because
Deadpool has a computer program that
monitors their vitals and their healing
factor and every time they start
regenerating flesh he hits him with
crazy-ass flamethrowers and just
continually burns him alive negating
their healing factor and perpetually
burning him alive and killing him and
burn him alive and killing him
that's pretty gruesome I think Deadpool
takes the cake on that one
and that's just one kill earlier or
later on that issue he's wearing beast
skin as a hide it's pretty that's pretty
brutal uh he blows spider-man's head off
Oh head off okay that glow spider-man's
head off he boasts uh Frank castles head
off he kills everybody pretty much kills
everybody that's just miss this for
issue all right the title of the arc of
Deadpool kills the Marvel you okay it
kills everybody you know a point of one
by one thing with that though cuz good
know cuz like that that is cool that is
like really cool I can't do that with a
care dig I do it with dimple and stuff
like that what I like about the mask
though is that you know again there is
the sort of invulnerable character but
he goes up against someone that's also
kind of like that a word invulnerable
it's a super muscle-bound guy and
everything they thought this guy like
you know might hurt him a bit but even
then just barely and no matter what they
do they can't kill this person and
there's this incredible battle in the
mask return series where it's just the
mask going up against this guy against
Walter and they all they do is they just
shoot guns throw punches stab each other
just nothing but blood flying everywhere
throwing grenades and stuff like that
and neither of them are getting anywhere
they might lead a little bit but I mean
just none of them are ever being taken
out and I think that kind of battle is
much more interesting when you do find a
tower person who is invulnerable and for
like a completely different reason and
the fight thing is there's no reason for
them to be fighting after a while
there's just they realize they could be
escaping maybe the cops are coming or
something but they just keep going cuz
it's that we're pride issue it
pride at least to insanity and I think
that is so cool when because I don't
know what Dipple ever has like an equal
in the comics I think he is just sort of
his own entity which is cool but I think
it makes for a much more interesting
battle when someone else can't die as
well or seems invulnerable and that
battle there never is like a clear
winner in that battle either eagle when
Walter comes back there's never really a
clear winner and I just think that's the
coolest thing they have so are these two
involved vulnerable forces and for
completely different reasons well that's
a perfect transition to our last topic
who would win if we mashed up the mask a
vs Deadpool hmm and why well I I got us
a mask kind of can assure you you really
don't you know no but it's tricky with
the mouth cos Deadpool is one dude do
you know and a Jesus one antes you know
the mask is passed on from person person
if kiss is not in the mask very long uh
you know he actually gets himself out of
the picture very quickly and then is
passed on the Callaway has passed on to
the sched to do then is passed on to
Katherine it's passed on all these
people uh so a lot of and as they go on
there's only it starts off with a few
little differences it was still mainly
the green face and they are crazy and
stuff I mean maybe I'm a little bit of a
goal but then as they go on they start
as you can see they forms are these
different outlines and stuff like this
one will look very different from like
you know I like that one or something
like that you know Katherine you know
will look very very different so instead
of just being the green face they Sully
form their own personalities and some
react to the mask very well and can
control it sunken hold on to it for a
long time
others like they pull it on they
immediately go nuts and insane like an
it gets his case so it kind of depends
whether or not you get someone who's
gonna keep it together or just go
totally nuts with it uh either I think
would be very effective and would make
for a really really good battle would
you think that the more insane you are
the more powerful you get and quicker in
the mouth it's hard to say cuz Deadpool
is kind of crazy - yeah absolutely
he goes back and forth the whole time as
well so it's really really hard to say
and even like I was going through trying
to think like well which one with the
mask would hold up the best against you
know Deadpool and it's like they're all
kind of different and but death will
kind of flip flops - I think just any of
them would probably work would probably
get like a good reaction um probably not
the ones from hum for great October
those I read I do you know they that
that might be like a little bit weak if
that's like a father-daughter they do
play to like the sympathetic side but
the others they just get lost to it
pretty quickly um I probably say either
if kiss because he was the first one to
get he's the one that
totally insane just goes on a killing
spree for no reason at all
uh and then on top of that maybe uh
maybe either the gangster or the or
Katherine cuz Katherine goes the longest
against Walter uh so maybe then but it's
I think it's kind of up there either or
you know can take him on uh you know
I'll just say he can he has the
advantage of cos he can control he
remembers where Myka can't control uh
how the violence happens to and then can
use it against Deadpool okay well see
you're talking about multiple different
people in this net may be different
multiple types of average series that he
would be facing you got to remember when
you face Deadpool Deadpool has multiple
personalities and now in inner monologue
shout stuff that other personality
usually help helps him and um in
Deadpool annual number one from 2000
Danu airy 2014 which I have right there
it's the explanation how Deadpool got
one of his personalities and is actually
the villain madcap and they got
obliterated apart and electrified into
ash by Thor's lightning bolt and when
they healed they healed together so
Deadpool had the body and madcap kind of
had part of his brain and they worked
together as each other so you've got two
villains and you're facing them working
in tandem in an invulnerable body that's
an incredibly strong adversary and then
later on he loses madcap or whatever but
he brings in this one federal agent and
she gets melded into his consciousness
or whatever to save her soul in essence
but you have a federal agent inside
Deadpool when she's trying to keep him
good but she's also a tactical person
she knows tactics on top so you got them
to working together and then Deadpool is
a huge tactical genius and the fact that
he is the tactical genius combines with
the fact that he's freaking insane
nobody knows what he's gonna do
Wolverine doesn't that's how he kills
everybody in the Marvel Universe because
nobody knows what Deadpool is gonna do
except for Deadpool and sometimes maybe
not even Deadpool he just does shit and
it's awesome so trying to go against
someone who just is just off the cuff
crazy and just uses it to his advantage
it's going to be hell of a hard time and
then Deadpool Deadpool Deadpool whatever
he's in mask costume whatever Deadpool
Deadpool but with your masks they be
taken off and it's transferred to people
isn't that Deadpool's a tactical genius
you would form some way to get the mask
off of that person and then take the
mask and destroy it bury it in 15 feet
of concrete something he would he would
make sure that that adversary is gone
the mask is kind of like the ring in
lure the Rings that has a way of gain to
the next person that you know you bring
up two interesting points one is that
you're right it can at some point the
mask has to stop being the mask because
they don't they go crazy have to take it
off and we should go to someone else
somehow I think you should that person
either gets killed off or you know
something that happens to him um but
some of you were talking he said uh
Deadpool has all these different
personalities I'm like a ton of
different multiple personalities and
stuff like that and with the masks they
do a little bit of the backstory that it
was you know some sort of like you know
entity or something that's in the man
sometimes the masks even talk itself so
it's always kind of like the mask and
whoever the mask is on having this
battle that leads to a good question
what's easier to control the mob or the
person mm uh because with the mask it's
oh it's just two people fighting you
know the whole time it's you know the
person has the mask on and the mask
itself and the mask always wants to take
it 20 steps further than the person
wants to you know and usually the person
will eventually fall into it with
Deadpool you know it's tons of people
arguing all those lines and it's like
whether or not you know you can sort of
hone that mob to work with you you know
which case you know you got more
personalities more people working for
you or if it's just always they're never
gonna agree it's always gonna be a mess
well I think most of the time I've ever
seen is two other separate empties
wherever and they you know show it by a
over the different style boxes or
whatever you know one's more somewhat
regal in the terms of the way he speaks
but he's very level-headed and other
ones like a different version of crazy
than Deadpool but often happens to be in
line with crazy dead but with the
regular Deadpool but then the more regal
one is a little bit more of the common
sense era but he he helped he uses to
help Deadpool like you missed this and
stuff like that so you've got an angel
initial yeah but the angels also kind of
morally ambiguous and that works so I
think he's got all these people wanting
to back him up
like Kronk's devil an angel from
Emperor's New Groove how long does it
have
how does Dipple have like arguments with
like as other personalities and stuff in
your monologue arguments all the time
because like they usually come out
together and like they're like we'll
know this in this rule how are we
killing with this deal with this like
it's always like okay like hey I want to
do this in the air personality it's like
no I do not want to do more often with
the the federal agent the woman I can't
remember her name is from I think
Duggan's wrong anymore but now what I'm
going to with that is that the more
often there's usually that conflict in
that argument usually the weaker the
battles can because you both won't be in
the same the same page and with the mass
they always start off on the same page
like always uh you know there's always
like the mask is just happy to be doing
crazy shit and whoever's wearing the
mask wants to do something with it you
know every good or bad so they always
start off on the same page so I think
even just the time when you come across
and could play a big impact as well cuz
like if you know Deadpool is not
agreeing with himself and then the mass
comes in like having just put on the
mask he's probably gonna have the
advantage but like if it goes down the
line with the mask is like notes is
going too far I don't want to do this
you're telling me insane and Deadpool
and his thoughts are on the same page
and he's gonna have the advantage so I
think again just kind of depends when
you come across them and another thing I
think Deadpool wins because he's a
martial arts master and weapon and a
weapons master he can use anything to
his Vantage guns knives swords anything
he's proficient in most weapons and
almost all forms of combat and then he
throw on the fact that he's crazy mixes
on the haul up that's a huge factor and
then in earlier issues a dead please a
teleporter so he might run out of
bullets and the scenaries not to be able
to manufacture him out of thin air like
the mask can he'll just teleport to one
of his weapons caches boom rocket
launcher like no problem I'm back and
I'm gonna kill you like so the maps can
do that too he can be anywhere any play
he doesn't have to go get again he
always has the gun you know always ain't
gonna do kick you know he's in grenade
can always have any of that stuff on it
usually yeah but I think that uh it
would be I think it would be harder for
the mass to realize when Deadpool is
going to be doing stuff like that
because
like Deadpool's unpredictable well you
can tell the mass crazy and he'll pull
shit out of anywhere it's like okay he's
gonna do something crazy when I do this
I'm gonna do this well something else I
forgot to bring out to that this is
something they brought in later as it
went on the mass can change the
environment too like he can subtly go
into a room and it's only like a
Twilight Zone parody or it's like a
circus that you in or something like
that so the environment can just
completely change uh based on what mood
he's in as well which is something I
don't think that Dipple can change
himself he can change wery anything with
him you can change but it can't change
the environment issue so I think that
can really sort of mix them up - all
righty well we are gonna move on to our
picks of the week Doug what is your pick
of the week for us uh my pick of the
week I'm gonna if you can read the first
max on the pussy you know like the first
collection that's probably a good thing
to do start off but the one I think is
the best whichever came when I suppose a
little it's somewhere in the middle is
the mask Returns collection this is the
one where it gets the probably the most
gory probably the most story going on
there's much more of a connective
narrative to it and it just has the
greatest battle with the mass camera
laser this is also about before with the
two entities going at and with the masks
and Walter just constantly doing machine
guns and flamethrowers and grenades and
they just go nuts and crazy and you know
it's just one of those things where it's
like the absolute stubbornness and the
creativity of how far look at it that is
insane as insane Alex was in this um
just the absolute length they can push
it and they just it I guess a is that
pure pride stubbornness that I think
just makes such a good battle and but on
top of the rust it is really good - and
it's really twisted and messed up I mean
as we know Deadpool is twisting messed
up - uh so it's a - really should fight
I think they should do something
together
once you hit crossover yeah I would yeah
don't be so let's get a mask movie -
let's get it why I mean not the Jim
Carrey one let's get a gory gritty man
yeah definitely that would be really
cool I read a little bit of the masks in
preparation for this and
I was super super surprised at how
ridiculously gory and just off-the-wall
it was and I really enjoyed it from what
a little bit I read of the Omnibus I
liked it better in the movie yeah oh I
mean the movie has very little to do
with the original but ya know it's one
of those things where it's like you know
you kind of read it it's like yeah this
is sick this is twist but holding my
attention I want to know what's going on
I think there's a lot of comics out
there that are just Gorp or it or like
saw or something where it's just like
you just watch to see that stuff happen
but you want to know what's gonna happen
next in these stories and I think for
kind of that gore poor thing I mean it's
like it's it's tough to do and I think
these characters are interesting enough
and the stories are just simple enough
but just you know
hinto complicated this is Porter Pick of
the Week I mean denticles got so many
awesome titles out there and like this
one Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
is a fantastic read and it sets up this
overlapping arc of different titles you
got Deadpool kills Marvel Universe
Deadpool kills dead Deadpool kills
Deadpool Deadpool Killa straighted where
he goes throughout literary history and
kills off these book tyrannies literary
characters Sherlock Holmes Moby Dick
like Deadpool trying to kill Moby Dick
is amazing and you whale he kills the
whale yeah you try you scene with a
harpoon it's awesome cover on it it's
fantastic and it heat these sets of all
these crazy a story arcs and they're
just so fun and then you've got his
regular comic run which is full of nuts
just absolutely nuts when he came back
with Deadpool in Marvel now like he had
the dead presidents and Tom thomas
jefferson's ghost was totally chillin
with Deadpool and he was a you know
horny little bastard it was super funny
and Deadpool and Thomas Jefferson talk
to each other about shit is it's just
comic gold so I mean there's tons of
stuff you just get just go find a
Deadpool comic and read it and you'll
love it Deadpool suicide Kings is one of
my favorite little story arcs it's
fantastic awesome sounds great
there's a million but whatever
there's a lot of unfold to go red go
read it go check it out also go check
out the masks you can also check out
these guys on social media Doug where
can we find you you can find me at this
address yeah I'm gonna be an asshole
again oh you just put it at the bottom
it's family okay okay you mix it up okay
so whatever you match you do this time I
just go I have face book pose obviously
gonna channel awesome calm and see all
the cool stuff to do there
awesome quarter facebook.com slash
awesome for supporter poor sir
I can't go there that's a different
thing yeah you don't want to see this I
know everyone's gonna go there now they
gotta know what's there
yeah I really wanna know thank you you
I'm gonna one get the other person we
don't know and then you know the awesome
comics show Facebook yep um yeah so
we'll have new videos up every Thursday
exclusively on Facebook so go check that
out again if you didn't earlier in the
episode now we're towards the end you
can go check it out now you can find me
on Facebook and Twitter and here as
always but not here this chair is really
comfy and Walter it likes to take it all
the time I think really possessive of
the peer assessment this year it's a
great chair though and I like it um so
yeah thanks for joining us let us know
in the comments down below who you think
would win who your favorite character is
and what characters we should do next
absolutely yep yep like less chances
alright guys and see you here next week
I'm Iona Wade and for the guys here
we'll see you on the next page
[Music]
[Applause]